>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Hey, everybody,
let's get started.
My name is Sasha; I work here
at the Library of Congress.
Hey, guys.
>> Hello.
>> What school are you guys with?
>> Halioma [phonetic].
>> Halioma; I knew that.
And what grade are you in?
>> Fifth.
>> Awesome.
Have you guys been here before?
>> No.
>> Well then, welcome,
for the first time ever.
So I have a weird question, so
who knows what day is tomorrow?
You're in fifth grade; you know.
>> Presidents Day.
>> What date?
>> May -- I mean, [inaudible].
>> We're not there yet.
[Laughs]
>> March 1st.
>> March 1st; and what is
March, what month is March?
I'll tell you, it's
Women's History Month.
So to celebrate that
-- starting that month,
we have a very special guest today.
So this right here is a renowned
scientist, Dr. Svetlana Kotliarova.
I know, that's a hard name.
She has a very interesting life.
So she was born in Russia, and
studied in Tokyo University.
Tokyo is in what country?
>> Japan.
>> Japan, yes, way more confident.
All right; and that's where she
got her PhD in humans genetics.
And then she worked as a cancer
researcher right here in Bethesda,
Maryland, a couple
minutes down by Metro.
She currently works as a
scientific review officer
for the National Institutes
of Health,
and she'll tell you a
little bit about that too.
She has completed a lot
of award-winning research,
and has written about her findings
in very important scientific
journals.
So you can tell she knows
a lot about science,
and she is really excited
to talk to you about it.
So let's welcome, everybody
clap, Dr. Kotliarova.
[ Applause ]
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: All right;
thank you very much for
such a warm welcome.
And I just want to make
sure everyone hears me well.
On the back you can hear me well.
If you don't hear, you just
shout it, "We don't hear you."
Okay? All right; so you
can just call me "Dr. K."
for short so that everyone
can do that, right?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay.
If you have a question, so
raise your hand and we'll try
to answer all the questions
you have.
If we don't have enough time,
you e-mail me your questions,
and I will try to answer them.
Yes? You have a question already?
[Laughter] Yes, please?
>> So oh, we have [inaudible].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
You do Sam's Club?
So you know a lot about science?
So who loves science?
That's great.
I'm so excited.
[Laughs] So --
>> [Inaudible] projects to do.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay, great.
So if we will have enough time,
in the end we can also
can do some cool stuff
with the equipment
that we have here.
How about that?
>> Yes; that is [inaudible].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So
-- okay, you have a question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Lava lamp; which one, this?
So this is just water and I
put some water color in that.
But let's talk about
this closer to the end
when you can do something
with it, okay?
All right; so [foreign
language], what did I just say?
Did anyone understand?
No. What language was that?
Do you --
[ Overlapping Comments ]
Who said Russian; yes, good guess.
So I was born in Russia, and
I just welcomed you saying,
"Good morning," [foreign language].
And I was born just in the
kind of middle of Russia.
So this is Moscow.
Who knows Moscow is
the capital of Russia?
Okay; so Moscow is
the capital of Russia.
You also have another Moscow here
in the US, maybe several of them.
So and I was born here
in Ural Mountains.
And the nature there
is so beautiful.
And I like to watch like
water flowers, butterflies,
and caterpillars, some
of the insects I was
scared of so like spiders.
And still I don't like them.
So and but the life, all the
beautiful creatures, attracted me
and I was interested how we have
all these different forms of life
and how they all function,
so what makes them alive;
I was interested as a child in this.
And this is some places
from my home place.
This is the natural -- oh, sorry,
national hero or Bashkir people.
So Ufa is the capital of the Bashkir
Republic, which is inside of Russia.
And this is the national
costume of the Bashkir people.
And as I told you, there
is very beautiful nature,
so you can see some of them.
Ufa is a big city; it's
more than a million people.
But there are a lot of
beautiful nature places outside,
and some beautiful buildings also.
This is a church.
And my family, we lived
in the suburbs of Ufa.
It was quite a poor area.
I didn't think about
this when I was a child,
but now I realize about that.
So this is -- so it doesn't work?
Okay. So we lived in this house.
So it was a small apartment, one
bedroom apartment, three windows.
Here is where my family lived.
And we had three people.
So here is, me and this is my baby
sister, and I also have a brother.
And this is my mother.
And so I was a girl like
you, so about the same age.
And this is one of the
two dresses that I had;
and another was probably washing.
So [laughter] in the -- and
we didn't have -- for a --
I remember the times when I
didn't have a washing machine
to wash the clothes,
and washed them by hand.
And we never had a drying
machine, so I put the clothes
to dry just using the
air, natural air.
And this is my school where I
loved to go, because there was
so many interesting stuff.
And you already told
me you love science.
And so this is what I
started liking at school,
especially when we started learning
about general principles
of life, like genetics.
Has anyone heard about genetics?
Okay, I see some hands;
that's great.
So we'll talk about this
a little bit more later.
Oh, okay, now it works,
so the three windows.
[Laughs] So this is my
path around the globe.
So I was born in Ufa,
you already know.
If you see it anytime in
your life this picture,
you know where it is, it's in Ufa.
And I went for my studies
to Novosibirsk.
And I told you already I love to go
to my school, to be with my friends,
to learn interesting things.
And It was kind of hard for me
to choose what I wanted to do.
I already told I loved biology,
but to go to study biology,
I'd have to go out of my home city.
So I was kind of scared about that.
And I thought, "I also
love English."
So due to some reason, my
parents put me into a school
where I studied English
from the 2nd grade.
I thought, "What a strange
idea my parents have,
because I don't see any people
speaking English around me.
I never saw anyone traveling
abroad, why should I know English?"
But standing here today, I
say if I didn't know English,
I wouldn't be here with you
today, not enjoying your company.
So it pays to listen to
your parents when they say,
"You have to learn something."
One day, you will realize
that it was good advice.
So and I was thinking, "Okay;
maybe I go to my local university
and study English,"
because I, believe it
or not, started to love it.
First I was like -- I didn't
know why I'm learning it,
but then I loved it.
And then my cousin came
and he said, "Why would you
like to translate people's
thoughts?"
So this was the only application
that we could think about just
to translate something
from English into Russian.
"You go ahead and you
bring your own thoughts.
You like science, do
something, do science.
You have your own ideas,
try them, test them."
And I said, "Okay; maybe
I'll go and give it a try."
And we didn't have SATs
like you have here.
I just had -- if I wanted
to go to some university,
I would go to university
and do my exams right there.
And I couldn't go to many places.
Usually, university will
have entrance exam in August.
And the best universities also
to give another chance to people,
they did entrance exams in July.
And so I went to Novosibirsk,
which was very good in science.
They have good science
measures there.
And the exam was in July.
I said, "Okay, if I fail
it, I go back to Ufa,
and go to my university
and study English."
And then, believe it or not,
I passed the exam,
and this was my path.
And one more good thing
happened in Novosibirsk,
I studied there and
I loved the studies.
First it was general studies
about all the biology,
and then very specific studies
studying about molecules of life
which is called -- molecules and
biology, how would you call that?
What would be the science?
>> Molecular science?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Molecular biology,
study about molecules,
biological molecules.
And one more thing happened there.
I met my best friend,
and my husband,
and my life supporter
for all my life.
And he is sitting here,
Dr. [inaudible].
[Laughs] [Applause] So
he has also some stuff
that he can show you in the end.
So he's also a scientist.
So and then we went
together with my husband
to Japan to continue our studies.
So what's another good thing about
science is that it's international.
You can work anywhere
around the globe.
You collaborate with all the
researchers around the globe.
And I did my research in
the University of Tokyo,
and I got my PhD degree
in human genetics there.
And then I worked a little bit more,
and traveled to many
scientific conferences.
This is another thing that is cool
about science, that you can travel
and present your research.
And we loved so much
how the research is done
in the United States.
And eventually, we came to the USA,
and to the National
Institutes of Health.
This is the biggest research
institution in the world.
And you have it just 30
minutes from here on the Metro.
So you are all the lucky ones.
So and I'm working now in the
Center for Scientific Review
at the National Institutes
of Health,
which is for short
I will call "NIH."
So can anyone tell
me what science is?
Okay.
>> Science is something
that you figure out,
or make it into something
that's fun out of -- or --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
You make fun --
>> [Inaudible].
Someone want to build
on that answer?
Do you want to build on
that answer, Marigold?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: It's okay.
You can do it.
All right.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay.
>> Science is like something
that you make -- make --
something that you make --
something that you create
in the world, that you make.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Something
you create, that's very good.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
What's that?
>> When you want to do
science, you have to start off
with your topic question.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes,
yes, very good; very good.
And you have an idea,
and you want to test it.
This is part of science.
So it is the way you learn about
how things work in the world.
And you explore the world.
So this is what science is about.
And there are many different areas
of science; fields of science.
So someone already said about the
question, so how science works.
So first you need to
have your question.
And how do you call the question
in scientific words; a hypothesis.
You've heard this words, I'm sure.
So you can have just a question,
"I'm interested what happens if --
" or, "If it is -- if I do this,
I believe I will get this."
So it can be different ways
of approaching science.
And then you do what
to test your hypothesis
to your question; you
do something, yes?
>> You do your experiment?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Exactly; you do your experience.
And for the experiment, you need --
>> Money?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Some money;
[laughter] you need some stuff
to do the experiment,
right, you need your object,
you need your device, you
need protection device.
And then you will do your check.
You will get some result.
You need to analyze the result.
Then you will develop your
understanding and your theory.
And you need to share that.
You put your -- you
will write a paper.
So scientists need to think.
Scientists need to
do interesting stuff,
and also to write; so
see how many skills.
And where do you get
all these skills?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Are you getting any
of these skills now?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
Where is the place where
you get all these skills?
>> School.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
School, that's right.
And you put your knowledge
into the library,
and then before you
ask your question,
you may want to also check,
read some books and see,
"Has anyone before we
asked this question?
Did they get an answer?"
Because in science, you
want to know an answer.
And if someone already has
an answer, you say, "Okay,
I like this answer," or, "No, I
think the answer may be different,"
and you do your experiment, so
and you develop new technology.
All right; so the best thing
to understand what scientists
do is to do an experiment.
So who wants to do an experiment?
So okay I need two
assistants right now.
So oh it's a difficult task.
Okay; you in the front and
you in the front, okay.
So we will have two assistants.
And what else do we
need for the experiment?
So we have our question;
we have our plan.
So what else do we
need for an experiment?
Okay.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Glue?
>> Gloves.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Gloves.
Okay, okay; yes?
>> You need protection over
your body, so [overlapping] --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Protection over your body; yes.
Like this?
And we have one more person.
[ Background Talking ]
You need the protection
for your body.
And you need something else.
So we need to -- yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
[ Background Sounds ]
Okay. And very important thing,
you need to ask your supervisor
can you do the experiment.
So before I come here,
I ask Miss Karen,
so can we do the experiment here?
So who is your supervisor?
[ Overlapping Comments ]
Yes. What if you wanted to
do an experiment at home,
who will be your supervisor?
[ Overlapping Comments ]
Exactly. And you will ask
them which lab can you use,
can it be a kitchen counter, or a
basement, or your classroom, right?
So we have the laboratory.
We have an approval.
We need also supplies.
So we need an object, which will
be our peeled and unpeeled oranges.
And our question is like which one
will float in the bowl of water?
So any ideas?
Yes; you need gloves, sorry.
[Laughs]
>> On the table.
>> One is on the table.
>> Okay.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Thank you.
[Laughs]
[ Background Talking ]
So anyone, who is thinking
the peeled orange will float?
And who is thinking the --
oh, sorry, I have the orange
that has the peel in it, right?
So you think this will float?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: And
the orange without peel --
so it's about like half
and half, 50/50 percent.
So why do people think
this one will float?
[ Overlapping Comments ]
Okay; let's go ahead -- yes?
>> Pass the microphone
to one of the kids.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> I think the one
without the peel is going
to float because it's lighter.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Because
it's less -- it has less weight.
That's a reasonable idea.
And those people who think
this will float, why?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> I think the one with
the peel is going to float
because it has protection.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
It has protection.
Okay, let's see.
So who is going first?
>> The one with the --
>> The lady.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
The lady, okay.
>> Lady; the lady.
[ Background Talking ]
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: All right.
Yes, put it in --
>> That's going to sink.
[ Background Talking ]
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
So what is the idea?
So -- yes.
>> The one with the
protection floats and --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Protection.
And what's in this protection?
What's inside this
peel that protects it?
Yes.
>> The fruit.
>> Fruit.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Fruit?
>> Orange.
>> Water.
[ Background Talking ]
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So this
something -- I give you a hint,
should be lighter than water.
So what is lighter than water?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Yes?
>> Air.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Exactly; that's a good guess.
So then we have --
thank you very much,
volunteers, you are real scientists.
And you will have your small reward.
[Laughs]
>> Thank you.
>> Good job.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
[Laughs]
[ Applause ]
All right; and now we can test the
idea that it's the air in the peel
that really helps the
orange to float.
So the next two volunteers,
so gentleman over there,
and the lady from the back row.
>> Good job.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
All right, so come here.
[ Background Talking ]
Put on your lab coats.
All right.
[ Background Talking ]
And you can put on your gloves.
For you.
[ Background Talking ]
All right.
So it's you who said it's
the air in the orange.
Okay; now you will test it.
So we have another set of -- how
about these are smaller and lighter.
So what will happen with this?
So any ideas; yes, please.
>> I think they're both
going to sink at the bottom.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
They will both sink?
Okay; who has another idea?
Okay.
>> I think that both of them are
going to sink, because the one
with the peel doesn't have as
much strength as the other one
that has that much strength.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So you think
that it doesn't have
this big protection,
so the peel is thinner, that's why?
Okay, you.
>> I think they're both going
to sink, because they both look
like they are lighter
than the water.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Oh,
you think that they're
lighter than the water.
All right, are our scientists ready?
Okay. Do you want to
use your goggles?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, [inaudible].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: All right,
one for you and one for you.
So now you will find the answer.
[ Background Talking ]
So --
Which one would you like?
Okay.
[ Background Talking ]
The lady should be first.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Wow.
So what is our conclusion?
Yes, please?
>> That the one with
the [inaudible].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So it will
sink because it doesn't have a peel?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
And -- okay, and -- yes?
>> [Inaudible] because we thought
that they both were going to sink
because they would be lighter
than the peel -- I mean the water.
One just floated, and
the other one went down,
because it didn't have any
protection [inaudible].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So these
ones still have protection?
Okay; and you.
>> The one without the peel is
[inaudible], so the water's going
to go in the hole and it's
going to bring the orange down.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes,
yes; that's all good answers.
And you?
>> I think [inaudible] because the
surface is matching the surface
of the water and it's keeping
it stable so it would stay up.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So
the surface of the water?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So the
peel helps the orange or Clementine
to stay on the surface of the water?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay.
These are all great answers.
And so someone said
the peel will help.
So can you come here, please?
So thank you very much.
Another great scientist.
[Applause] Okay.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Talking ]
So who said about the
peel, the peel is the key.
All right, come here.
[Laughs]
[ Background Talking ]
>> Good job.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Great job, yes.
[ Background Talking ]
Great job, everyone.
[Applause] So we can do an
experiment just with the peel.
If the peel is the key, should
it sink, or should it float?
>> Float.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Float.
Okay.
[ Background Talking ]
Great. So can I try too?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Mine also floats.
So this is the peel that
makes the orange float,
so and exactly the air in the peel.
So thank you very much.
So we solved one scientific
question today.
[Applause] Thank you
very much, everyone.
Did you have a question; no?
[ Background Talking ]
All right.
So we analyzed results,
so we made a conclusion,
what makes the orange float.
And if you were doing a scientific
project, you would make a poster
and present it at the
scientific conference
in your school about this.
And this way you will -- or maybe
you go to your parents' home tonight
and do this experiment with them.
So you will show them, you
will spread your knowledge
to other people.
This is how science works, and
you will make other people excited
as well about this new
thing that you learned.
And this is where scientists go,
to the scientific conference,
talk about their work, and
they start collaborations,
new ideas develop during
these interactions.
So where people do science,
where do scientists do science?
Yes.
>> In a lab?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: In a lab,
yes; and where this lab would be?
Yes.
>> In a laboratory?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Laboratory,
yes; and laboratories could be
in a company that may be working
on developing some
drugs against disease.
It can be in a university.
Who knows labs in the universities?
>> Which universities
do you know carry labs?
You all have these groups at school.
>> Ooh.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Who has heard about Johns Hopkins,
which is just very
close to us, right?
GW University; yes,
these are all around you.
So all these universities
have labs which ask questions
that are important, and they answer
these questions doing experiments.
And also there is the biggest
research institute in the world.
I told you about that.
What is it?
>> National Institutes of Health.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
National Institutes -- exactly.
And this is not one
institute, it has 27 institutes
and centers inside;
that's why it's so huge.
And more than 20,000
researcher or people
who help researchers are working in
this National Institutes of Health.
And if you think about
it, so who uses toothpaste
in the morning to brush their teeth?
That's an awesome group.
[Laughs] So and who knows that there
is fluoride in your toothpaste?
Yes; and what does that fluoride do?
Why do they put it
in the toothpaste?
Yes, please.
>> It makes it taste flavor.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: You
think it's for the flavor?
Who thinks something else?
Okay.
>> Like when something is
like stuck on your teeth
and you try to clean it out, like --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: It helps
to clean it out, you think?
Okay. And what do you think?
>> To clean your teeth?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
To clean your teeth.
What do you think?
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; this is exactly
what it does, fluoride.
And that fluoride protects
your tooth enamel from decay.
This is what's found at the
National Institutes of Health.
Who likes to go to the
doctor and get vaccines?
Oh, not too many.
>> Shots; shots.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Shots, yes.
>> So no.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So not too
many, but some, there are some.
And why do you like to get shots?
Why do you like to get shots?
Yes, please.
>> To keep me healthy.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Exactly.
And some of these vaccines,
for example,
for hepatitis were developed at
the National Institutes of Health
to make you healthy so that you
do not get sick from these germs.
And you heard in the news
like last year or something,
or about two years ago
that there was Ebola.
And NIH worked to eradicate
Ebola virus.
So NIH also made a
sequence of human genomes.
So read all the letters
in your genome;
and we will talk about this shortly.
So there is a huge center
at NIH that fights cancer.
So these are the institutes at NIH.
And just name some disease, and
you will find that there is someone
at NIH doing research on it.
So any disease you know?
Yes.
>> Kidney disease?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Kidney
disease, yes, there is the Institute
for Kidney Diseases; yes, see,
digestive and kidney diseases.
Yes, please?
>> The flu.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Flu;
flu is an infection, right?
And so the Institute of Infectious
Disease will do the study.
Yes, please?
>> Is Zika virus [overlapping] --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Zika
virus; so also infectious disease,
because it can be passed to people.
Yes, please?
>> Cancer.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Cancer; this
is the biggest actually institute
at the NIH, National
Cancer Institute.
And I worked for it; I was studying
brain cancer in that institute.
So yes, please?
>> Skin disease?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Yes, skin diseases.
Where will be the skin --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
So there could be different skin
diseases, as I'm hearing from here,
like allergies, there could
be allergy on the skin, right,
that could -- it could be studied,
then, in the Allergy Institute.
It could be skin center, then maybe
National Cancer Institute will study
it; and skin diseases, yes.
Yes, please?
>> There's one called vitiligo?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Ah,
vitiligo; so where would that be?
It's also the skin, right,
but it also affect --
it's a systemic disease so it
could be also different institutes
that study it, several
institutes could study that.
So and you can -- it's
a funny thing --
not funny, but fun thing that
you can be part of NIH too.
NIH has programs for
high school students.
And once you want to do research,
you think you want to try,
you can go for the
summer to work at NIH.
Yes, please.
>> I don't know if I
shared with you all,
but NIH paid for Miss
Hutchins to go to college.
College was completely free for me.
And they are responsible
for your teacher
to become a published
scientist [overlapping].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
[ Applause ]
That's --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; NIH has a lot of funding
for researchers who do research.
And it also helps people
to go to studies so --
as your teachers, so
which is awesome.
[Laughs] So and who
has a computer at home?
Yes. Who can access
computers in school?
Who can go to the library
to get to a computer?
Great, so what do you
do on the computer;
not playing, something else.
[Laughs] Yes?
>> You can go and like
learning websites?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Library?
>> Learning --
>> Learning websites.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Learning websites, that's great.
>> [Inaudible] is a reading website.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Reading website; okay.
Yes?
>> Research about history?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes; you
can search about different things.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; great.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
It helps you with your
homework; great.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes. Yes, please.
Okay, great; these
are all great answers.
Yes, please.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
To help you with math; okay, yes?
To search about scientific topics.
And this is a great place.
At NIH every institute
has a website for kids.
So you can go find kid
resources or games.
And you can find fun games about
science at the NIH website.
And if you do a scientific
project, you can also go there
and search are there any
answers to your question,
will it help you to solve them?
So and we will -- I will summarize
all these resources in the handout
which I will give to Sasha and she
will e-mail it to your teacher.
So you will have these
links to all these resources
so that you can access
them whenever you need.
So who can be scientists?
What scientists do you know?
Yes?
>> Albert Einstein?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: What's that;
Albert Einstein, this
is the scientist.
But I'm talking about general; what
qualities does the scientist have?
Yes.
>> [Inaudible] curious?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: You
should be curious about science,
about the world around you, right?
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Persistent?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: What
does it mean, "persistence?"
If things don't works, so if
our experiment doesn't work,
so you give up and you say,
"Okay; I don't do it anymore."
[ Inaudible Comment ]
You think about another
ways, someone said, right;
what other way will work.
So you do not stop, you try
to find another approach
to answer your question.
So this means "persistence."
And you need to be very
interested to find something new.
And can you imagine a
scientist who stops learning?
So it's for your life you continue
and continue to learn new stuff
through new experiments,
through reading books,
and reading research papers.
So it's a continuous process.
So and you can be a scientist.
It doesn't matter where
you were born.
As you see, I was born
very far away from here.
And just you need to be interested,
you need to ask advice
maybe from many people.
I had very good teachers
who could give me advice.
You have an awesome teacher
here, and other teachers
in your school who you can ask.
And there is a whole website
on how to become a scientist.
And this is -- I just took
some parts from that website.
I will also link that -- make that
link available to your teacher.
So the most important
thing that scientists do --
>> Is never stop learning.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Never stop learning and read.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, exactly.
And we are in a great place
where you can read the books.
And you can go to your libraries,
you can go online to read.
The scientists also write.
Yes, please.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Speak up.
>> You can get your masters
degree and your scholarship.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Yes; you can get --
after you graduate from school, you
can go to college, get your degree.
Yes, please?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Speak up.
>> Are all these books for science?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
All these books?
>> She's asking are all of the
books are on science topics?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
These are about scientists,
about scientists, and
about science, yes.
And you -- the cool thing
is that you are going
to get one of these books.
So I just wanted also to let
you know that there are some --
as you told me, you go to get
your degree in the college
to be a scientist, but you
can get a masters degree,
you can get a PhD degree.
But there are some cool science jobs
that do not require a
very advanced degree.
And some of these, you can be
an environmental technician,
learn about nature around
you, test if it's good water.
A sonographer can look
inside the body
and check whether everything
is fine there.
You can be -- if you like
working with animals,
you can be veterinary
technician, or a nurse.
And it's a cool job to be a
forensic science technician
to solve the crime, who did it; and
a biomedical engineer to make an arm
or a foot for people who need that.
Tell me if you know
any famous scientists.
Yes, please.
>> Albert Einstein.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Abraham Lincoln -- what?
>> Albert Einstein.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Albert Einstein, yes.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> He said, "Come back to me."
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Come back; okay.
All right; so there are --
you probably heard about
Galileo Galilee, yes?
>> George Washington
Carver; he's a scientist.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Who is that?
>> George Washington Carver.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Okay; was scientist?
>> He's a botanist and [inaudible]
for everything that you know
about the peanut [overlapping].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay.
>> George Washington Carver.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay,
okay; I didn't get the name.
Okay. So Albert Einstein,
you told me; Newton,
you heard about him, yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Can you speak up?
>> Matthew Cherry [phonetic].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
So what did she do?
>> He invented the bicycle.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: All right.
>> The bicycle.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes?
>> Madame C. J. Walker.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay.
>> She invented multiple
hair products
and beauty products for women.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes, yes.
So previously, like
in the old times,
science was mostly men things;
so mostly men were scientists.
But the things changed
during recent times.
And you will learn about many
famous women from the book
that will be provided to you
by everyday -- "Everybody Wins!
DC." So you will have this great
book about women in science today.
And some of these scientists
from this book are also
shown on this picture.
And scientists can
be very different.
Yes; anything?
You will think about it?
>> She knows who the astronaut is.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: You
know who the astronaut is?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Speak up, please?
>> Dr. [inaudible].
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes,
that's right; that's right.
And all know about Marie Curie?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: And the
famous physicist, Chien-Shiung Wu,
who is in this book,
and Patricia Bath,
who developed the treatment
for eye disease.
And today we'll talk a little
bit about Rosalind Franklin,
who is also in this book.
And she's a very famous
scientist, because she was the one
who found the structure of
the main molecule of life.
What is the main molecule of life?
>> Bacteria?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Do you know about that?
How is it called?
>> DNA?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: DNA.
That's great, you know.
Wow. [Laughs] And remember --
and can you imagine that many,
many very good scientists,
very bright scientists were solving
the puzzle of the DNA molecule,
how it is formed, how it can be
replicated from cell to cell.
So in the cell, we have
the nucleus inside.
And all the DNA is
inside this nucleus;
and how it can determine
who you are.
Every one of us have
the DNA in our cells.
So DNA, as I told you,
is in this nucleus.
But it is very, very long;
they're about a 6-foot tall person.
And you if put all your DNA
from one cell, it is so long.
One string of DNA is very long.
But it's very, very compactly
organized inside the cell.
So and how do you think
how many letters are there
in the genetic code.
So there --
>> Eleven.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: You know,
26 letters in the alphabet
to make all these work.
But how many letters do we have in
our cells, like in our genetic code?
>> Four?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Who said four; great.
So we have these four letters.
And I need two volunteers.
So you didn't come yet;
come please, and you, yes.
So can you tell me how these
letters can be organized?
So they go together.
So this is the pattern.
So there is only one way how these
letters can combine with each other.
Can you figure out?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: And
this is always the rule.
Yes, that's correct.
This is always the rule that
we have a letter T goes with A,
and letter G goes with C.
And we have only four letters
in our genetic alphabet.
So and this is how we go
together, how they're organized.
And then this molecule
will be twisted.
So you saw the picture
of that, right?
It will be twisted, and twisted,
and twisted so it becomes very,
very small, so that it
can get inside the cell,
inside the tiny nucleus.
So thank you very much.
[Applause] You volunteered,
and I give you something also.
[Laughs] Okay.
And I forgot to give --
[ Background Talking ]
So this is just what we saw, how
DNA forms so-called double helix.
And these are the tools, cool
tools that the scientists can use.
And these are also in your book.
So you can study these.
And we will have a
present for everyone
so to memorize the four
letters of the alphabet
of the genomic -- genetic alphabet.
What are these letters?
Who remembers how they're called?
>> A, T, and G.
>> A --
>> A, T --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: A, T --
>> G, C.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
And A goes with --
>> T.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: And G --
>> Goes with C.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Great.
[Applause] And this is the
cool thing about the science
that so many smart scientists
for decades were figuring
out what you just learned
during these last five minutes.
And you can figure out
something even greater than that.
So it is -- if you really want to
be a scientist, you can be one.
And it's just your
imagination, which limits you.
So don't let it limit you.
Expand your horizons by learning,
speaking with all your
teachers, and reading books.
So you will find many
inspiring stories in this book.
I read some parts of it.
>> Will we get it today?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
You will get it today, yes.
And I don't know if we have some
time for another thing or --
[ Background Talking ]
Ah, okay, we have -- so if you --
did everyone get their bracelets?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
There should be color codes;
so the codes show the
letters of the --
>> I have H.
>> I have C.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
You have H, you have C?
>> I have H.
>> M; M.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: M?
>> C.
>> M.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Okay;
so C means you got a the piece
of the chimpanzee sequence.
>> I got H.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: H is part
of the human sequence of DNA.
>> C.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Butterfly means B, right?
>> What about M?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: And
M is a flesh-eating microbe.
It's a microbe.
It's a cool thing.
If you don't like it -- the girls
don't like it, you can exchange it
with the boys for a butterfly.
[Laughs]
>> [Inaudible] C.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: C is
chimpanzee; chimpanzee's DNA.
>> Who got D?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
So this is for you
to memorize the four letters
of the genetic alphabet.
So thank you so much
for coming today.
>> Thank you.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: All right.
[Laughs]
[ Applause ]
And --
>> Questions?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Ah, questions?
Yes, please.
>> So the experiment, how did
you come up with this experiment?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: How did
I come up with the experiment?
So honestly speaking,
I saw it online,
[laughter] so this is
where you'll find it.
Yes. [Laughs]
>> Thank you.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: And I
thought it will be a good experiment
that we can show, because I cannot
give any explosion here, right?
That would be cool though, right?
[Laughs]
>> Yes.
>> Why is the water sizzling
after we put the oranges in there?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Why is the water --
>> Like why is it bubbling after
we put the oranges in there?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Bubbling?
>> Like -- yes, like --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
These bubbles?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Have
you ever put water in a glass --
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
From the sink?
>> From the --
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
So what are these bubbles?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Someone thinks evaporation.
>> Air bubbles.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
You answered yourself; right.
So the thing is when
you ask the question,
your brain starts thinking, and
you can come up with an answer.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> She said you're right.
>> What made you like science?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: What --
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
What made me like science?
So actually, I like -- started
liking science when I was a child,
like as I saw like the plants,
the insects, the animals,
I always bring some animal --
like some animal, like the dog,
some cat from the street
to my house;
I like all the living creatures.
And when we started
studying genetics in school,
this is when I thought it's
so cool it has also math laws.
If you heard about Mendel,
Greg Mendel who made the
first genetic experiments.
This is so logical.
And it can explain how things work,
how all creatures are
working, how we are made.
And this is what made me
very fascinated in science.
Okay? Yes, please.
Yes, please.
Oh, you have the microphone; okay.
>> My question is how old
were you when you started
to experience that
you liked science?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: How old
I was; so thinking about science,
maybe when I was in high school,
like seriously thinking
maybe doing science, yes,
when I was in high school.
But as I say, I liked animals
from when I remember myself.
But if it will be my major --
I wasn't even sure when I
went to university what area
of science I will be doing.
And while taking courses
in different sciences,
I chose something that I like most,
and went into that
specialization, okay?
Thank you.
Very good question.
Yes.
[ Background Talking ]
>> How old were you when you decided
to travel from Russia to come here?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
From Russia to come here?
>> Yes.
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: So first
from Russia, we went to Japan
to do the graduate studies.
I was already very old, I think.
How old was I?
[Laughter] I was -- at that
time, I thought I'm very old.
I'm not thinking that I'm old now,
but at that time I
thought I was old.
I was like 27 years old, yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that?
>> Don't say you're old
because people will say
that you were real young.
[Laughter]
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: That's
what I'm saying, now I'm --
at that time when I was
27, I thought I'm old.
But now I think I'm young.
[Laughter]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes?
>> One more; one more.
>> What was your favorite
part about science?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova: My favorite
part about science is that it is
so different, and you
can learn many things.
So you can choose whatever
direction you do.
You can focus on certain
areas, do your research
like I was doing brain
tumor research, for example,
trying to find some new drugs
for treatment of patients
with brain cancer, and something
that was tested in clinics later.
And that makes -- it's very exciting
that you can contribute
to human health.
And also, nowadays when I'm
doing work in grant [inaudible],
I see the new projects
that are coming currently.
Like the investigator
will write a proposal,
they want to do certain research,
and we assemble a team of reviewers
who will check if it's good
research, is it really needed now.
And this is very exciting to see
what kind of science is currently --
is like a newborn science,
so all areas of science.
And you can learn in
your special area,
and you can expand your knowledge,
you can collaborate with people.
So these are also things
that I liked very much.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> First of all, thank you so much
for speaking with our
students today.
It's such an honor to have such
a brilliant scientist presenting
to us, and the extensive
research that you've done.
Of the research that you've done,
what is your most proud
discovery thus far?
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Oh, my proud discovery;
[laughs] so I would say maybe it
is two things, one that I was doing
when I was a researcher
in the University of Tokyo
when we were discovering
the areas in human genome
that could be associated
with different ethnic groups.
And I found several specific loci
in human genomes that were specific
to the Japanese population,
for example.
And you also -- because these
were on X and Y chromosomes,
you could also by analyzing these
loci determine is it a female
or male.
And so this -- and
the previous things --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; the one that I
already mentioned briefly
when I was doing brain cancer
research working on a drug
that was testing in the clinic
and we found additional targets
that could be targeted in the brain
tumor that would help patients.
Yes, so that's --
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Svetlana Kotliarova:
Thank you very much.
Yes.
>> Thank you very much.
Another round of applause for Dr. K.
[ Applause and Laughter ]
Thanks for coming, everybody.
So just like we said,
"Everybody Wins!
DC" got each one of you a book.
So you're going to pick
it up and read it, right,
and then you're going to be
come super-curious people
about science, right?
>> Yes.
>> Is that right?
All right.
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.